écoute
j'aimerais pouvoir t'aider mais pour ça
va falloir tu me donnes un nom semble
être des cordes répond ouais ok café
ouais je vous dis
avec du sucre
oui
tu dis stop
avec lui les way
bon maintenant tu vas venir quelque
chose d'énorme la cannelle satire est un
petit peu de cannelle réponds bah oui à
dire je suis pas contre
j'imagine que tu veux quelque chose à
grignoter avec spéculent au creps
pancake un petit nuage de chocolat
spéciaux club paquet nuage de chocolat
on met de la crème de marrons de petites
noix de cajou
butor et noisettes quelques noisettes à
nous allons bon
trois peines est rappelé qu'à ça lui
fera brutalement
non vraiment ça y est voilà quand tu
veux allez dégage dégage
alors
ben alors qu'a fait beau mais le sérail
et ça
si tu veux voir une alternative à ce
sketch cliquer ici si tu veux voir une
autre fin alternative cliquer là si tu
le peux cliquer ni ici ni là
les liens sont en description de cette
vidéo